yeah welcome to this game against max
Avila hmm not sure it's not a player i
know but doesn't mean much okay let's
play the the Bogle mmm yeah naughty 6
this is so how I play it we are
preparing a 5 with 97 95 and yeah can I
castle yeah
so could have taken let's take no
yeah one idea that black has in this
position is too he wants to preserve the
bishop I don't want to take if he plays
Knight c3 for example I want to to put
it on c5 and use it on this diagonal a7f
to sometimes you have real oh no not
Bishop d7 don't want to blunder the porn
okay play this play this first attacking
the the bishop get all the way back okay
so I've attacked the peace now on d4
so I'd like to play Bishop d7 Quincy 8
Bishop 83 years something like that also
I wonder hmm is this insane h5 come on h
5h for Neji for stuff like that it's
very crude but it's blitz chess let's
let's try
hmm yeah really with the f porn and it
was an idea maybe with the f porn sex
sacrificing this to get the F R okay so
what now this is some rocky five as the
kind of move that comes to mind my play
you for though not sure I take and a
droopy five
rookie 5
27 I don't know let's check it again
rookie 5e for Bishop f5 takes 97 and
then it's got 95 m and that's a shame if
I play play very very directly night g5
and Queen to Queen g5 h5 something like
that is this I come on let's try this
it's um it's of course very very brutal
and maybe complete complete bogus but
it's fun quite often the sir super
directplay can be can be really
problematic to defuse
yes
so Queen g5 is this is this completely
ridiculous Queen g5 it's not clear if it
is threatening something really
okay he needs so he needs to take I wait
97 I can play em I can play 13 even rock
III this is a cool move rocky 3 I can
take c5 if I take on III with the bishop
sonai g7 Bishop b3
yeah it's probably not really working
one idea that I had beside all this is
97 rookie five just blocking the
diagonal and this Bishop I this night on
g7 doesn't really have a square and his
he's thinking it's a it's not easy okay
of course there's also a simple stuff
like Queen age six then he needs to move
the Roku this much is clear but what
about those other moves look III for
instance I really like this i DM yeah
we'll take on c5 with woodland with the
night
that's really a shame okay I need to
play move this is far too complicated
for for for a blitz game okay maybe this
and now Bishop takes no one cannot play
Bishop takes hmm Bishop takes Knight
takes bishop f2 maybe this is completely
incorrect probably F takes yeah I take
with the rook yeah no I thought this
move
and Knight f6 ah what a shame i cannot
move the king now because this is a
check this is a check Wow then then he
can play in our queen f2 and and
probably win yeah what a shame at here a
lot sure maybe it was all [ __ ] what
I played but it was it was interesting I
thought and and funny Oh what what what
I need to count them I need to count
first what is this yeah I'm very much
down on material ok so let's resign this
it was hey I know Mike my gut feeling is
that I had a very good position but I'm
an optimist Queen g5 ok Knight takes
well computer doesn't give me a direct
win but yeah I probably played a wrong
sacrifice this is clear I need to take
with my problem was what I didn't see
this is losing yeah this is losing I
didn't see her after this that Knight f6
as is a check this is the problem or
rather that on i def six I cannot play
king ii 8i thought I just play king e
aid but he's got rookie hey check this
is the problem in my in my brief
calculation can can put it on
here I thought okay just just here but
he's got rookie 8 and I didn't see that
I only saw this and this this is winning
I forgot about rook e8 and this means
it's not it's not working at all but I
can take here and this is in fact okay
for black um what is why it's supposed
to play here computer gives Queen f2
with the draw hahaha wow
yeah well if should take jet
this completely crazy variation leads to
a draw what even even this is a draw so
I can what is this material wise I
cannot hurt if I do this here it's
really amazing like it's not able to
pick up a minor piece this is cool what
yeah I cannot win a minor piece
apparently Queen against for minor
pieces I mean that would win one then I
would have two pawns and his king is so
open maybe okay a little crazy game I
hope you've enjoyed it